У цьому господарстві на Львівщині не чути сирен повітряної тривоги й обстрілів.
Тут саме закінчують сіяти пшеницю - уперше за багато років роблять це до кінця березня.
Земельний банк у нас вісім з половиною тисяч гектарів, і серед них 400 гектарів займає яра пшениця.
А наступні культури, які ми будем сіяти, це соняшник, соя, кукурудза.
Разом це під три з половиною тисячі гектарів.
Але війна і тут вносить свої корективи.
Цьогоріч агрофірма пана Зіновія сіє на третину менше кукурудзи.
Адже для її сушіння потрібен газ, а ціна на нього - нестабільна.
В іншому, за словами керівника господарства, дефіциту немає - добривами запаслися, робочих рук не бракує.
З нашого підприємства двоє людей пішли добровольцями, два дуже висококваліфікованих спеціалісти пішли.
Але в той же час до нас повернулися два спеціалісти, які на зиму поїхали на заробітки в Польщу.
Вони вже під час військових дій повернулися до нас, в наше господарство, вони зараз вже працюють на посівній.
Тракторист Роман за кермом із сьомого класу.
Ця посівна для нього далеко не перша.
Нині його односельчани приймають у себе переселенців.
А сам він свою роботу в полі вважає важливою місією.
Хто до чого вроджений, всі не можуть бути музикантами, льотчиками, столярами.
На Львівщині вже вирішили віддати більше земель під зерно, картоплю й овочі,
аби компенсувати тимчасову втрату територій на півдні й сході.
За різними оцінками, цьогоріч від п'ятої частини до третини ріллі в Україні
неможливо обробляти через бойові дії.
Подекуди поля заміновані.
Пан Зіновій певен, що до західних регіонів російські війська не дійдуть.
Утім, переймається, чи зможе збути свій врожай.
Якщо не продасть зерно - не матиме коштів на наступну посівну.
Наше господарство в попередні роки десь приблизно 90 відсотків врожаю експортувало,
тільки 10 відсотків тут, на внутрішньому ринку.
Експорт переважно йде через Чорне море, через одеські порти.
Що буде, як буде… Місяць серпень, місяць вересень - ніхто зараз не скаже, ніхто не береться прогнозувати.
Тим часом посівна триває в 11 регіонах України.
Сільське господарство працює навіть попри бойові дії.
Михайло Травецький - власник молочної ферми під Прилуками на Чернігівщині.
Його невелике господарство опинилося в одній з найгарячіших точок.
Біля нашого села фактично проходить траса сумська - Суми-Київ,
і з тієї сторони завжди ідуть колони орків, ну, російської армії,
і час від часу відбуваються бої і знищення колон, перепалки,
і фактично це відбувається над дахами моєї ферми.
Усі корови на фермі Михайла - рідкісних українських порід.
Чимало тварин він врятував зі скотобійні.
Про своє життя й роботу на господарстві Михайло знімає відеоблог.
Утім, у перші дні війни, за словами чоловіка, було не до зйомок -
усі його підопічні, по суті, залишилися без корму.
Це просто був армагедон тут. Нам потрібно було… Закінчилася моя кормова база.
Я купував, їздив по сусідніх селах, у фермерів сіно брав, зерно брав.
Усе нормально, хлопці заготовляли, у них є місця для сховища.
І бах - почалася війна, попідривали всі мости, попереривали всі дороги,
і фізично ти розумієш, що скотину годувати нічим.
То, я вам скажу, була досить напружена ситуація, уже не знаю, хоч самому лягай у те корито.
Урешті корми й сіно вдалося знайти в сусідніх містах і селах,
допомогу запропонували навіть глядачі Михайлового блогу.
Нині, попри роботу артилерії неподалік, на фермі триває життя.
Осьо дивіться, маленька красуня.
Ой здрастуй, привіт, ось сосочка.
Ось така Джавелінка у нас народилася маленька.
Ми всі тут у теробороні, кожен знає свою позицію, місце, фізично ми готові захищати.
А куди евакуйовуватися? Це наша земля, наші домівки. Куди я поїду від своїх корів?
Кожен думає, хто чим допомагає, хто волонтерством, хтось зброєю в руках.
А я так подивився, я в тиждень виробляю, виходить, десь півтори тонни молока.
Ну це, я вам скажу, по масштабах, це 200 літрів на день, це не так і багато.
Але якщо взяти півтори тонни молока, то більше тисячі людей беруть у мене молоко.
Я розумію, що точково ось такі "Михайли" - якраз шанс для всієї цієї округи.
Невеличкі - у кого 10, 15, 20, 30 корівок.
Ми зможемо на сьогоднішній день закрити продовольчу кризу в нашому регіоні і в нашій громаді.
Оптимізм українських аграріїв став прикладом для цих двох німецьких фермерів.
Тім і Торбен працюють в Україні вже десять років, керують великою фермою в Західній Україні
за 60 кілометрів від Львова площею 1900 гектарів і працевлаштовують 25 людей.
Потім прийшла війна, і німці на якийсь час виїхали з України.
Мої перші відчуття, коли я виїхав з України разом з багатьма іншими людьми, - просто смуток.
У нас сльози на очі наверталися, бо ми не розуміли, що відбувається, що сталося.
Зараз ми тут, готові діяти.
Та нещодавно німецькі фермери повернулися назад - організувати посівну.
Почали з посіву цукрових буряків, а згодом також буде ще кукурудза і соя.
За час, проведений у Німеччини, німецькі фермери зібрали 130 тисяч євро пожертв для України,
організували доставку гуманітарної допомоги і допомогли розселити 170 українських біженців довкола Берліна.
У нас на заході України ситуація з поставками відносно нормальна , продовольство є.
Те, що ми зараз доставляємо в Україну, іде завдяки нашим контактам через друзів і знайомих в регіони бойових дій.
Там ситуація катастрофічна. Якщо Київ буде оточений, як Маріуполь, там нічого не залишиться.
Наші люди зараз їдуть у Київ.
Тим часом українські фермери - і Михайло з Чернігівщини, і Зіновій зі Львівщини - певні, що Україні голод не загрожує.
До того ж, для аграріїв уряд запровадив пільгові кредити, акциз на пальне скасовано.
Для невеликих ферм, таких як Михайлова, знизили податок до двох відсотків.
Для внутрішніх потреб України продовольства більше, ніж достатньо.
Але українські чорноземи годували й близько 400 мільйонів людей по всьому світу.
Україна - один з п'яти найбільших постачальників продовольства на планеті.
Поки Чорне море заблоковане російськими військами, суховантажі з українським зерном простоюють у портах.
Найгостріше брак українських товарів незабаром можуть відчути на Близькому Сході й у Північній Африці.
Однак і до німецьких аграріїв уже докотилися наслідки розв'язаної Росією війни.
Дітер Лауфер удобрює свої поля пшениці на сході Німеччини.
На добривах економить. Вони стали надто дорогими, як і паливо.
Росія була важливим постачальником цих продуктів.
Дітер сподівається, що цьогоріч йому вдасться отримати хоча б мінімальний прибуток з господарства.
Чимало країн, таких як Молдова чи Латвія, взагалі не можуть собі дозволити закупівлю добрив.
У багатьох країнах бракує дизельного палива, через це подекуди неможливо розпочати посівну.
Фермери, котрі встигли запастися пшеницею, зараз добре заробляють, адже ціни на зернові високі як ніколи.
Ця компанія з півночі Німеччини відправляє пшеницю в країни північної Африки через Гамбург і Росток.
Залежно від щоденних цінових коливань, пшениця коштує десь 450 євро за тонну.
Потім її треба відправити в Північну Африку, Іран, Саудівську Аравію, Єгипет, Алжир,
а це додаткові витрати на транспортування - від 40 до 50 євро за тонну.
Тож кінцева ціна - приблизно 500 євро за тонну.
Багато господарств в Україні працюють із сучасними технологіями.
Це одна з причин, чому держава продавала пшеницю й продовольство у різні регіони світу -
від Індонезії до Нігерії - за прийнятною ціною.
Нині, коли експорт з України під загрозою, у світі заговорили про загострення глобальної продовольчої кризи.
Згідно з останніми дослідженнями ООН, кількість людей, які недоїдають, у світі наближається до одного мільярда.
Є побоювання, що ріст цін, який ми нині спостерігаємо, означатиме, що ще більше людей зіткнуться з проблемою недоїдання.
Нині Україна намагається налагодити експорт до Європи залізницею.
Але потяги зможуть забезпечити лише восьму частину тих постачань продовольства, що раніше здійснювалися морем.
За словами експертів, Росія шантажує голодом світ.
Не тільки блокує українські порти, а й навмисне обстрілює ракетами нафтобази під час посівної,
коли пальне конче потрібне українським аграріям.